these are animals that are being cruelly
hunted down lured out of national parks
in this instance and slaughtered for
someone's bizarre idea of a sport you
know so I hope that as a result of this
backlash this outrage that animals will
no longer be used for this sort of sick
entertainment it would actually be given
protection the protection they deserve
country specifically like Zimbabwe is
benefited dramatically from trophy
hunting over the last year's the
Zimbabwe's economy is completely
destroyed by what's going on there and
trophy hunting is one of the few few
things that still generates foreign
revenue creates employment it generates
protein for local people
if trophy hunting wasn't existing at a
lot of places in Zimbabwe right now the
people will be poaching and decimating
entire populations of animals making
these wild free-ranging animals extinct
regionally in those areas and those
populations wouldn't exist I think most
people listening to this program
watching this program would never
consider trophy hunting they want to
take a photograph of these animals they
don't take their lives mr. Lampert what
do you think should happen to these
they're two men that received this
32,000 pounds
look perching is poaching and if they
did not have a legal permit to hunt
those that that animal then the Lord
must be must be followed and they must
be prosecuted in the right way I don't
think dr. Palmer is as as much as at
fault as the international media is
saying yes he was the hunter but he paid
a professional in order to to have take
him and hunt that animal with him and
which the the procedures and the laws
and the firm eating of that country
should have been applied in 1976 they
closed all hunting in Kenya today
Kenya's animal population is down down
by 80%
that means that 80% of the animals which
once existed they don't exist anymore
because there is no trophy hunting
hunting is not the only solution it is
one of the key conservation tools which
can be applied
save Africa's wildlife I just think the
the the the suggestion the trophy
hunting is the panacea that will protect
Africa's wildlife is a rather ridiculous
statement and you know the the gentleman
on this program is really interested in
protecting his business rather than
protecting wildlife I'm interested in
protecting wildlife